yes
and the ability to to deliver
the best we possibly can for this
community i thank you in jesus name
amen
so welcome again councillors and i'll
declare
the march meeting open we don't have any
apologies so it's great to have a full
turnout a two day and i've just worked
out i've got a leg of a table right in
where i sit and get myself readjusted
and we'll be right
okay so we'll move on to uh declaration
of counsellor conflicts
is there any conflicts of interest that
need to be declared at this point in
time
uh councillor reed thank you your
worship
um yes i'd like to declare an interest
in
item one on the in committee agenda
please
okay thank you
any other conflicts there's not i know
that
anybody that has does have a conflict
will declare that if
it appears during the course of the
meeting so thank you councillors
um confirmation of the minutes of the
ordinary meeting of council held on
tuesday
nine february would somebody like to
move that be seen as a true and correct
record please
move council dixon seconded
councillor grant thank you
is there any alteration required to that
record
you think you worship page eight
mr taylor said that the board was coming
was not coming to the council for
funding to do the work in discussion
with mr toto last night
at an agenda meeting he was quite
adamant
that um it was referring to
tonight that night that he wasn't coming
there that night to ask for money
so um that's just uh not not a point of
clarification but just
let any councillors know that that
there may be in the future coming for
money yeah look i
i think that um that tallies with my
record of the conversation that was had
with mr taylor
uh last month too that while he wasn't
asking or on behalf of the board for
resources from the council
that night he wasn't discounting that
into the future
okay is there any other alterations
that are required to that um set of
minutes
there's not so with that one alteration
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
um is there any urgent late business
that needs to be tabled
uh tonight does not thank you
um so item five
and we have a
reclamation plan for the gore landfill
and we have um a report from
neil mir and can i just congratulate you
neil on on equality and the legit
logical way that you've worked through
the the challenges
of that particular issue and presenting
it to council tonight and it's really
good to
just see the history of where we've come
from and where we are now
and and developing a way forward
so there's neil niels here isn't it
um neil do you want to make any comment
before i open this for
discussion
thank you neil so the report is
open for discussion and
recommendation from councillors so
councillor grant thank you worship um
yeah i'd like to reiterate um the mir's
uh comments about is it's a very good
report
and i think this is probably your one of
your first reports you've given to the
council so it's great
um a question uh
2008 the goran district amenities
charitable trust
began the gordata forest restoration
project is is that trust all
active
it appears over the years there has been
several different groups
they've put towards the justice league
that there is still some
your recommendation at the end so you're
after that
what page were you on you're after the
twelve thousand
six hundred plus to twenty five thousand
is that that
um is not coming out of any budget this
is an increase zero
that's correct uh through your worship
yes
thank you
your thanks your worship i've just got a
question around um
amenity use um there's currently biking
tracks and parts of hamilton park which
have been
very popular and there's obviously an
opportunity to expand those does the
consent allow for
the clean fall to be to be used and even
if it's a temporary nature for 15 years
as some form of amenity i've just
traveled to iwakuni
and they've got a fantastic clean full
um
mountain bike tracks and much of the bmx
track which will be a large size of
what's here now and i'd seen the right
location for it does the consent allow
for
that type of activity occur is it very
much replanting back to native trees
through your worship i'd need to check
that out it's been a while since i've
looked at that consent for the landfill
the the clean fill if you could use it
would need to be
proven as being that clean fill and
nothing that
is hazardous to groundwater but look we
could certainly come back with a
supplementary report on that very issue
if you wish
yeah i think that would be uh be good
thank you um councillor high said
councilman fail
yet uh as you stated it's obviously a
very thorough and good report that neil
um
plenty of detail in there and a couple
of little factors that come out
um while looking at obviously i support
the fact uh regarding the green waste
particularly around uh the amount that's
going in there
and the fact that you pointed out
there's commercial users that are coming
in and
obviously uh dumping large amounts of
that and i see we're up to about
uh 900 tonne i think it is
um that they're forecasting um if we
look across
uh the community when we have um
obviously i think
about five thousand five and a half
thousand dwellings uh within the gauss
gore district um obviously there's a at
least a couple hundred kilos
allocated to each of those those
properties so i think there's probably
some merit in keeping the domestic
green waste for the domestic user but
obviously explore that commercial
side of it and and see if there's any
cost recovery there
um and other than that uh i support the
fact that
you also indicate there's there's been
problems or um
the fact of putting um
waste through that area and we don't
really want to hide any problems for the
future
so to make sure we do do it correctly
ensure that the money that we're funding
that we're putting in there is
appropriately used
to our best of abilities so i support
your um
your recommendations there
is there any other counselors that want
to make a comment uh councillor dixon
uh thank you your worship um having
recently been over at the landfill i was
a little bit
surprised to see the state it was in
really and the
the huge amount of crushed glass that's
been
kept there as well i was wondering if
there's any plans for the future
of that and whose responsibility is it
to um to deal with all the the green
waste that
as um council mcfarland said seems to be
becoming more and more of an issue over
there
yeah um in terms of glass do you want to
respond to that ramesh
our finding yes whether it is a clean or
not then we can use our existing query
to do a land filling there because which
is considered activity
as regards to the grass i think we are
investigating further options
other than the capping work how long and
durable we can make the
landfill to be capable in the next
report i think what we are intending to
provide council about
considering the comparison between the
fees and charges around
the neighboring councils and the way we
can rethink further rethink about the
how can we manage our solid waste in the
community
we'll have another comprehensive report
i think thanks need for his
dedicated effort in providing such a
comprehensive historical
information to keep up-to-date to the
council
generally the way fees and charges are
there this kind of activity should be
self-funding
but unfortunately we are planning to
have some review all the fees and
charges in the following
long-term plan but this year we need
something to be tidied up
because we know the problem i think we
need to fix it the amount he's
requesting
for through this report is not even this
i think
council should consider it
thank you ramesh in terms of the the
green waste
um as a regular user of the of that uh
landfill um there is a lot of waste
going into that maybe we were a victim
of our own success
in terms of opening it up for uh free
use and that's part of the discussion
today so
i look i think that wherever we end or
land and that particular discussion
uh will determine with the volume of
waste that goes into there
into the not too distant future
councillor heisted
yes is going to support the comments of
the councilman fail around green wasting
i think
it is time to reveal it across the board
even for domestic
um it was introduced during the covert
environment so we've had it in place for
must be almost a year now i've visited
other
neighbouring councils and you pay and
we've got to use a pay situation here so
i think we should seriously
reconsider our green waste charges
across the board
and is it appropriate to ask for a
report for staff particularly on that or
is that going to be part of the overall
waste management report that we're going
to receive
through your worship it's certainly the
intention of
post this report to assemble
that working party that the council last
month agreed to have
and the intention is to come up with a
suite of recommendations
my objective is to have them ready for
implementation on one july as you can
see there's budgetary pressure
and there's some unintended consequences
so that is both
the charging regime at the
transfer station but also the issue we
have in the community with our kerbside
collection
and current unintended consequences
about further
waste generation and the levees at the
landfill which are only going to go one
way and that's north
so all those things need to be put into
the mix the intention is to have some
rapid fire discussions with that working
party
so that we can come up with a suite of
proposals for the council to consider
i would think by hopefully the end of
may
council bulger just briefly i'd have to
say that central governments let
everybody down with no plan
to address the inability to send
recycles by overseas i mean
goodness me it's been well over a year
and there's no indication at all that
they're even
um charting directions so um
you know it's it's going to be difficult
for the working party to come back with
a
uh response to what we do with
recyclables their present
you know at present approach is to send
it to landfill which seems to be the
only
reasonable or sensible one storing it
and stacking it
you know that's just uh you know
not a good idea i don't believe
counselor phillips
thank you your worship i've just got a
couple of questions uh
neil just uh is it going to be an
outside contractor who's going to be in
control
of the green waste um just in my
experience
green waste is a a real pain it doesn't
matter how many pads you put down people
expect you to walk out with the carpet
slivers on to take the rubbish out
and when you remove it if it's not if
you don't bank up into a ramp
then the pads that you put down at a
considerable expense
get eroded by the machinery shifting the
the green waste is it going to be a ramp
and is the going to be under control of
the existing staff who are not council
staff
or is it going to be outside contractors
okay counselors um any other questions
for mr mia um
i'm just one question there is the
funding is that coming
from which budget
i guess this will be a request to go
into the long term plans uh
no worship this will be uh a charge for
this year um and will have to be managed
um you know overall financials
um so the funding for the
waste improvements will
be as per our funding policy where
the landfill itself is
funded via that part that's not funded
by fees would be funded by the
um we have a district-wide uagc
that covers the the network part of the
operation
and the landfill is the network as
opposed to the curbside collection which
is a
defined service that's delivered to each
household so it'd be a district-wide
charge thank you
okay any other questions if not we've
got
um two recommendations there
or three recommendations and asking for
direction
around disposal of domestic green waste
so um would somebody like to to move
either those recommendations or
propose a new one and develop a
recommendation around the green waste
counselor heisted so i guess the the
green waste
the recommendation would be that the
working party turned his mind to the
green waste as part of its
brief after following the comments
you may wish to add as a matter of
urgency
if you wish to try and send a signal to
the working party that
it needs to turn its mind quickly to
that issue yep or maybe
grant is there any just
any further discussion does not i'll put
the motion all those in favor please say
aye
against the motion is carried thank you
and uh thank you neil for the work that
you've you've done there
um we'll move on then to item six
um wiggin street uh waste water renewal
and we have a report from our three
waters asset manager
matt do you want to make a comment to
this um
pretty significant report matt
oh yes i'm happy to your worship
um yes so obviously um last year during
the february floods
um the working street wastewater maine
we had a section of it collapsed
and we undertook an emergency repair of
170 metres of that pipeline
and then following that in october the
council
decided to spend approximately 1.9
million
of the stimulus funding it received on
renewing
a further section of that ligand street
wastewater mate
since then we've considered some options
around the wastewater main renewal
and we've come to the conclusion that a
full replacement of the wastewater main
is preferred rather than perhaps lining
it or something like that
and due to this we're now recommending
that
an 800 meter section of the main is
replaced up to the intersection of quad
strip
in parallel to that we've had a
condition assessment completed on the
asbestos water main that runs down wigan
street
and this is identified that that that
water main is also in poor condition
and will be at risk of failure during
our construction works
due to that we we have included some
budget to replace it in the long-term
modelling that's currently underway
though we've now
based on recent tinder prices
and the work and the cost that
the cost of replacing the initial
section of main we've now developed a
engineer's estimate
where we're estimating the total scope
of work to be 2.8 million
which is approximately 460 000 more than
what we allowed for in the lgp modelling
we have included the water main as a
provisional item allowing it to be
removed if we
desire and i suggest that that
decision was made once tinder prices had
been received
and we knew that the actual construction
costs
happy to take any questions okay
thank you matt so the item is open for
discussion
and or question and recommendation
counselor bulger
that would seem sensible to include the
replacement of the
water main and the documents to find out
what that option would uh finally cost
i think to
do the renewals and then find at the
waste that the water main failed
subsequently
and then have to dig up the road again
would not be a good look
okay open uh council garden
can we design the tender to fit the
money
so in other words the price per meter
for the water main and the
sewage pipe and just move it up the
street to any amount of money and you
can put
the tender out for x meters or x dollars
of
work and then the next section will be
the next go
do you want to make a comment to that
man through your worship yes
we could certainly do that um that is
one option that we can consider
you further comment from counselors or
questions counselor hosted
so on this basis we're not committed
we're just seeking a request for
proposal
and as this situation involves we can
view it so the council won't be on a
path on a train it can't get off
that is correct thank you
okay if there's no further questions on
matt
will somebody like to move the
recommendations that we have
in the report council bulger second to
council mactanelle
thank you uh i'll put that motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
right um we'll move on then to item
seven
and we have a memo uh from the chief
executive
uh with regard to the three waters
reform probably the
the largest um influencer of local
government
uh on the horizon and and one that we
need to be
very up to speed with but um
steve do you want to talk to your report
uh yes thanks for worship um i i guess
i've gone out a little bit
on a limb here uh to
unlock me worship uh in regard to
the predominant mainstream thinking
within the sector that is just reform is
inevitable
and you shouldn't really question it
that
the public entities the government is
proposing are
pretty much a slam dunk certainty and
it does concern me that there hasn't
perhaps been enough
thought given to what the world might
look like
if councils had more funding from
central government
particularly given that a lot of the
or some of our challenges are directly
derived from
directions from central government in
terms of increased standards
and that's particularly germaine well
germain to both but
while this council has
been able to i think meet the challenges
in the midst of meeting challenges with
drinking water standards
um the resource consent renewals
required for wastewater
which help will have a big um
influence from the new national policy
statement fresh water
means that we are facing some
extraordinary costs
so the reason why i just wanted to
pause and challenge the first wording of
the first principle the wording of the
first principle
was that it was just a given that uh at
the current system is unsustainable
it is but it might be it might be
possible if we had an injection
of government funding similar to what
happens with roading and bearing mining
free waters as
a critical form of infrastructure
justice roading so
that's my my point of worship i just
think that it behooves the sector to be
cautious about reform to equip itself
about what the options are
and it does concern me that the
government is
offering a timeline where councils are
being asked to commit themselves
unequivocally to a reform process
when we don't know what the actual
future state of the new entities is
going to be like
because the design is still a work in
progress so we don't know
how many entities um what
level of influence any local count local
communities will have with that entity
and obviously the type of
priorities that may be afforded to those
entities
along with what does it mean in terms of
pricing for water
so all those things need to be teased
out
in my view before councils can
reasonably make an informed decision so
hence i'm just probably setting out some
words of caution that we need to be
asking questions
and not just sleepwalk our way into a
reform
that may not prove to be uh provide
all the answers that i think everyone is
looking to
um to identify and secure
thanks steve and and i don't disagree
with the sentiments
at all i think that local government
could do the job
if the funding package was there i think
one thing
that we do need to realise is reform
is is on the agenda and to use the
terminology that
council heist said used a few minutes
ago
there is a train on the track however
i think that the the warnings and
the the messages that you have sent are
ones that we need to um
you know to behove um and certainly the
three waters
group that has been working on this um
i'm sure has got that in their minds as
we
as we speak but councillors will be
aware that
next week there is a a special meeting
of both the otago and the southland
councils
with the dia to
for them to share a lot more information
with us so
i'd like to think that by this time next
week we'd have much more information
about
the shape of whatever this reform is
going to look like
and what part we have to play in it
but certainly one thing we do need to
realize is that
going going forward the way we are now
isn't going to work
it isn't going to cut the mustard and
we need to make sure that whatever the
reform looks like
whether the local government is involved
in it or not we need to make sure that
the residents of our communities get the
very best deal they can
in terms of delivery of safe and secure
water supplies
and i guess the other thing that we need
to make sure that's in the back of our
mind as well
if indeed the count the government do go
down the track of reforming this
completely away from local government
in whatever form it might be then
there's a very big question there about
what is the role of local government
into the future because delivery of
water supplies and waste
being taken away from our communities
has been a big part of
our operation and every council's
operation for a long time
and and what would the council look like
in terms of
form and function if it wasn't there
certainly the capacity the engineering
capacity that comes
to this council via the the water
department
is significant and it is
it will leave quite a big hole should
that move
anyway it's open for discussion
councillors and
i look forward to hearing your thoughts
but i am very mindful that this is a
live discussion with government
and as i say even this time next week we
may have a
slightly different perspective on it
given some of the information we will
get
and all councillors have been invited to
that meeting
so open for discussion
allow me to be um
somewhat controversial you wish someone
like you
if it's something about money
you know we've got the capacity um to do
the work
it's about money and and i i
you know if i was cynical i'd be
wondering if
central government's not playing you
know the political game i am interested
to see that naita who want to be
involved
and once again i you know it's about
money i i'm
happy to have a contribution from any
group including naitahu
um but actually we need cold hard cash
um once again i'm worried that it's
going to become a bit of a political
football
rather than a financial exercise which
is what it needs to be
so um that's my controversial comments
yeah and again they're not that
controversial i you know i agree with
exactly what you're saying i think that
money is a is certainly a big part of
this equation
um i think another part of the equation
is capacity
and capacity going forward to do to
do all that is required and and simply i
don't think there is capacity
not just in the local government system
at the moment to do what we need to do
in the time that we need to do it given
the expectations that are there
from government but i don't think the
immediate capacity is even in the
country
uh as at this point in time
you fail it's just a uh a question
of the ceo just in regard to
some confusion here page 39 in regard to
air
issues where we indicate it's 80
um second paragraph down in there
predicted that the word of debts would
rise from 80 to over 400
of the revenue when we refer to it under
the morrison and low
i'm just trying to clarify is that a
specific region because they indicate
it's 215
in their um summary there
and page 45
uh funding level investment would push
the collective
debts from a current position of 215
to 400 percent there's quite a
difference in
uh 135
there is that the variance they're
discussing
or have we got a bit of disparity there
just take me through again i've just got
the page page 39
and they have document that we've um
that's in the morrison low uh no this is
in the uh
the otago regional target south and
three waters document
we refer to an eighty percent debt
loading
second paragraph in the issues section
approximately abc into over 400 revenue
in the next 10 years
and in the morrison and low document
they refer to
summary there they're indicating a
current position of 215
so is there i'm just is there any
explanation and
is it uh are they including another
region or
uh with both reports
sorry i think it's clear that whatever
the correct figure is
it's significantly more than than we've
got at the moment yes
i agree with that but there's obviously
a bit of a disparity between those two
figures as well
um that's why i i read that as
morrison lowe's estimate of what it will
cost to do the work is 185
greater than what local government have
been
uh indicating through their long-term
plan um
morris and low aren't constrained by um
affordability so
much and and politics involved in other
words it's going to cost a lot more
money than anybody thinks
okay other comments
from anyone council dixon
just reading through the documentation i
was quite alarmed to see that councils
can be forced to provide a service to
rural properties
due to regulatory requirements under the
legislation and
that could be a huge financial
burden to all our rate payers
that was on page 51 paragraph three
yeah all right good point there's a lot
of imponderables in this one uh council
gala
yeah it could be some interesting things
come out of it at the end of the day
um my roading mostly funding is is
generated by
taxes on cars and trucks and there's a
top up from the central government
so basically i think that's what they'll
roll over water it will be
attacks with a water meter in and the
water meter out and um
when people get a water meter in the
water meter out there is
certainly some efficiencies done on the
private side
so that may drive some some good in the
system but
there's going to have to be extra
funding put in overall
there is no doubt the water meters
change people's behaviour
and that that's not all bad
um
um okay so move council bolted i've
signed over that council reed
thank you is there any further
discussion
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried and i
think um
yeah well certainly all councillors have
been invited to this meeting and i'm not
sure who's
going from from council council of high
state is there any other councils that
are going to be
the councilman fail and council bulger
now it's it's going to be interesting
i'll have to say
okay let's move on then to a local
government conference
and this year's conference is set to be
held in blenheim
as it was last year but was
postponed because of
because of covert
and i guess it's interesting the theme
is uh reimagining
terror from the community up i guess
whatever the
outcome of the water debate is or the
water
plan that's going to reimagine atro
as we know it anyway but certainly
there is an opportunity for a councillor
to be part of the delegation that goes
from from gore to uh the conference and
in blenheim and so i'm keen to
to hear from any councillors that might
be interested in
attending that i can say that on a
normal year
it's it really is a good and stimulating
conference
um and it's a fairly high caliber of
speakers
and subjects that that are being
discussed i suspect that this year will
even be a step
up on what we've had in the past because
of the reforms that
are on multiple fronts that we are
funding or not funding we're dealing
with
so um so i think whoever decides to go
hopefully somebody will decide to go
they'll find this
whole thing quite stimulating is there
any counsellors that want to
put their hand up council mcphail
you'd be keen to attend thank you
anybody else
okay um so we have a motion there
um that councilor macphail attend
the conference with myself and the chief
executive
and that myself as me are being
be the presiding delegate with uh
councilman mcphail being the alternate
moved councillor heisted do i have a
signal for that councillor davis thank
you
is there any discussion does not i'll
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors i think that
brings us to the end of the open
oh no it doesn't no item nine sorry
gambling
um and tob venue policy uh review update
there
um
so i got that have i
so we have a recommendation
contained in that that report and it
relates to
councillor grant being counting himself
out because of
a conflict of interest that has been
been pointed out
council need to appoint a another
delegate
to that position does anybody have any
burning desire to be on that particular
review
panel everybody's looking at their feet
counselor heisted
that's right okay um
is there anybody else wants to be part
of that do we need an election no it
looks like it's councillor heisted would
somebody like to move that
move counselor doug grant secondary
counselor davis thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion
is carried right that does bring us to
the end of the
open part of the agenda and
i would move that council move into